[Music]
the power of three will set you free but
will a reboot the charm to reboot has
been the talk of 2018 but will you be
watching we know about three sisters
whose names begin with P that won't
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up hit that notification bell to
stay updated on newest videos and don't
forget to check our community feature
now let's check out what's up with this
charmed reboot our reboots even
successful before we dive in some other
facts about the Charmed reboot we should
ask ourselves if reboots have actually
ever been successful filmmakers often
think of bringing back cult classics in
an attempt to bring in the old fanbase
and give them something new and exciting
we've had quite a few TV show reboots
over the past few years and many did not
live up to the hype
for example Business Insider put the
2016 MacGyver reboot to the bottom of
the list claiming it's trying very hard
to fit in series like Roseanne gave the
audience mixed reactions as the cast
turned highly political on and off
camera
but many reboots such as Gilmore Girls
queer eye Battlestar Galactica and
plenty more have turned out to be fan
favorites don't even get us started on
the fan outrage when they announced the
Buffy reboot could charm to make the
list of successful reboots or will it
come down crashing after its first
season there are way more factors to
consider before we make the decision
recycled plot so what's charmed all
about anyway well as it turns out it's
pretty much what a reboot stands for in
the original series we get to know Prue
Piper and Phoebe Halliwell the three
sisters that find themselves in their
old childhood home with the help of the
Book of Shadows a magic book located in
the Attic they discover that they
actually have magical superpowers the
original show was all about strong bonds
of sisterhood exploring the unknown
fighting everyday problems and sticking
together as family
the reboot looks like it'll inherit all
those traits it'll have a sensible
eldest sister the outspoken middle child
and the naive young college students
just like in the original one of the
detective characters falls in love with
the older sister but it looks like this
series will not have a whitelighter in
said they'll have a professor who takes
great interest in the three sisters the
plot also hints at a possible love
triangle between the middle child her
ideal boyfriend and a mysterious
character oh and their version of a big
plot twist is turning one of the sisters
gay promising too much fierce funny
feminist reboot at least that's what the
CW television network is calling the
series wait until you hear what the cast
have to say but it does make us wonder
where the original sisters not attribute
to feminism at all
it looks like the CW doesn't think so
the Mary Sue calm did a fantastic
breakdown whether or not the original
charmed can really claim the true
description of a feminist TV show many
comments are pointing out that although
the series had a lot of potential there
was still a subtle mix of 90s cliches by
the looks of it the Charmed reboot could
have the potential of bringing us the
feminist element that was lacking in the
original series but will this be a
successful formula that will blend well
and make sense to the audience or will
they face the same try too hard
criticism many reboots tend to get but
from the looks of it the original cast
are really not thrilled about this
project meaning the original fanbase
most likely won't be either exactly the
same roles the show will be using the
same familiar format we've fallen in
love with but it looks like the new
creators broke the rule that every
Halliwell sisters name has to start with
the letter P so while the roles are
exactly the same the names aren't we're
introduced to Macy Mel and Maggie this
proves that the show is using the same
formula but will this formula attract
today's audience the thing is their last
name is in Halliwell at all Macy the
older sister has a last name Vaughn and
Mel and Maggie's is Vera
not a single Halliwell insight it's not
really explained whether the older
sister is actually married or not
because we're different last name but we
have a feeling this will only add to the
juicy drama so far it looks like the
fans are skeptical whether or not this
show will work we'll really have to wait
and see if the formula is good enough to
keep the audience entertained throughout
the entire first season totally new cast
yep
not a single person from the old charm
team is coming back to give some
guidance on this show the 2018 show
includes a
and new cats Macy von is played by
Madeleine Manta
although Madeleine could be seen in
several TV series such as casualty and
the Tomorrow People the charmed reboot
could be her big break
Melanie Diaz who plays Nell on the show
has a slightly longer acting resume and
has appeared in TV shows as well as
movies but Disney fans might be more
familiar with Sarah Jeffery who played
Audrey in The Descendants TV movie and
descendants wicked world TV series it
might not be the actual movies but it's
still something now the original Charmed
actresses had slightly different resumes
prior to the start of the show Alyssa
Milano had two major successes first for
the iconic who's the boss and then moved
on to Melrose Place Holly Marie Combs
was a part of picket fences and shannen
doherty had an extensive acting resume
that included Little House on the
Prairie our house and of course the one
and only Beverly Hills 90210 will the
charmed newcomers have the acting chops
and experience to compare with the old
cast or will we have to sit through a
couple of episodes before we get into
the show it will get political here's
where Charmed could get complicated the
new series will be a politically charged
version of the story that's actually
meant to reflect our chaotic times
whether or not this will involve talking
about controversial precedents or
looking at things from a culturally
diverse standpoint it will definitely
bring a new layer to the show question
is will this layer turn out okay a good
example of a politically charged show
that didn't really go well is Roseanne
we live in a day and age where many
actors share their political opinions
online and in Roseanne's case those
opinions clashed with the majority so
much so ABC actually canceled the entire
show on the other hand fuller house
managed to perfectly balance political
humor as the character max shared many
Donald Trump jokes with his one-liners
let's not forget that this time the
charmed cast is much more culturally
diverse - but will a political point of
view totally erased the extra magic the
original show created by completely
ignoring politics with the rise of TV
show characters having strong political
Binion's this could be a hit or miss in
the magical world a real witch on board
over the last few seasons of the
original Charmed Holly Marie Combs and
Alyssa Milano both had a lot of say and
how the show was gonna look as they were
both listed as producers of course
alongside the show's brilliant creator
Constance M Burge this time around the
production team is slightly different
Brad Silberling Gina Rodriguez and
Michael a Alouettes
are all listed as the series directors
while Gina Rodriguez has been praised
for her acting abilities she hasn't
really had much directing experience
under her belt other than two episodes
of Jane the Virgin Brad Silberling has a
much larger production resume which
includes jane the virgin and dynasty
meanwhile Michael a Alouettes directed
the Vampire Diaries the flash Supergirl
and several more shows could their
powers combined really bring us a modern
adaptation of charmed with zero guidance
from the previous team well it turns out
they actually do have some guidance one
of the writers on the team belongs to a
real-life coven even practicing spells
and putting out energy toward goals he
wants to accomplish nothing like
telekinesis but hey he's only human
fans reactions weren't positive we'll
get into strong opinions from the cast
in just a little bit but first let's
talk about the people that made the
original charm such an iconic show a lot
of the fans seem to be skeptical about
the reboots outcome and we all know that
having an audience is the most important
part of the show going on for more than
just one season right so far it looks
like the majority of the og Charmed fans
just aren't on board enough to be really
hyped about the reboot some fans are
even pointing out that the show's
tagline is stronger together which
already belongs to a show called
Supergirl pin yup it's on the same
network and it's even directed by one of
the Charmed reboot directors others are
pointing out that the Charmed reboot
shouldn't even be called charm to begin
with since it doesn't really follow a
strong enough format to resemble the og
show since having a strong fan base is
key to having a successful show and a
renewal for the second season this could
be another reason why Charmed might not
make it past season 1 we're staying
optimistic but we're pretty sure the og
cast of the show are sharing the exact
same feelings as the fans cast members
are against it Holly Marie Combs made it
very clear how she feels about the show
but first let's check out how some of
the other Halliwell clan reacted to the
reboot news Alyssa Milano stated that
she wishes the creator would come to
them for some guidance from the
beginning even though she wishes them
the very best of success she also said
that the series feels too close to her
to have seen it being completely done
Janet Dougherty supported the idea but
argued that the producers shouldn't make
it seem like the original show wasn't
supporting feminism though she did say
that she's intrigued by the idea that
the show could gain and inspire a
totally new fanbase Rose McGowan
indirectly tweeted about the show saying
that Hollywood is running out of ideas
and that they are in her words lame lame
lame lame ursins those are some pretty
mixed reactions don't you think all
actresses have millions of followers and
with strong opinions like those chances
are the og fans might not really get on
board the whole charmed reboot thing
Piper Halliwell disapproves one person
that disapproves the entire project of
the reboot the most is without a doubt
Holly Marie Combs if you've been
following her Twitter account you know
she's been incredibly vocal about this
show from the moment it was announced
Holly said that the series is just
capitalizing off the team's hard work by
taking the name and completely rewriting
the story without asking them for any
advice Holly also pointed out that she
hopes the show is much better than the
actual marketing done so far as this
will be the only way it'll be able to
keep a fanbase she also said that
reboots do better when the creator's
listen to the passionate fan base and
based on this extremely vocal fan base
it doesn't look like this will really go
down well although Holly wishes the show
well she's extremely against it which
she pointed out in plenty of tweets or
should we say she's not exactly charmed
by it issue okay yeah horrible time
we'll see ourselves out but before we go
make sure you tell us what you think
about the charm to reboot in the
comments below and that's it for our
video thanks for watching see you next
time
[Music]